Hey everyone. My name is Melissa,
and the article I'm going to be discussing today is "Breast Implants: the emotional journey behind them."
We're surrounded by the idea that woman have to have large breasts, a large booty and a small waist
in order to be considered beautiful. In a environment like this, does having small breasts
make someone feel less feminine?
Breast implants are becoming more and more common. In fact, according to
the American Society of Plastic Surgeons, breast augmentation is top plastic surgery performed today.
A total of three-hundred-thousand (3.000.000) American woman recieved breast implants in 2011 alone.
Now, breast implants has been proven positive for the majority of women who recieve them,
they feel an increase in self-esteem, in positive body image, and in sexual satisfaction.
However, it has also proven to futher deepen more serious psychological problems,
like body dysmorphic disorder and depression. Woman who are planning to have breast augmentation perform
need to step into the surgery with realistic expectations, and the realization that having breast implants put in
won't magically make them feel better about themselves. If they have more serious body issues,
they need to sort those out before they get surgery. As David Wellisch, a professor of psycholigy in UCLA says:
"Many woman I've encountered simply aren't happy with their bodies and wish to improve them.
They have realistic expectations that if this is done, they will look more satisfying to their own eyes and others,
but their self-esteem does not depend on it."
While breast implants do help woman feel better about their bodies, it's important that a woman's self-esteem
does not depend on her cup size. A study of 24.600 woman, conducted by researchers from
Université Laval Faculté de médecine, the Canadian public health agency, and Cancer Care Ontario
found that the suicide rate among woman women with breast implants
is 73% higher than in the general population. General consensus seems to be that
if you are going to have breast implants put in, you need to love yourself before going into the surgery.
If you are unhappy with your body in general, you may want to take a step back and look in the mirror
before deciding whether or not breast augmentation is really the right option for you.
Now, while the studies that have been conducted are helpful, it's important to know
that only 24.600 woman were serveid, and considering that over 300.000 recieve breast implants in 2011 alone,
24.600 is a really small number compared to the whole population of woman who recieve breast implants.
So, the results that they got from that study could be slightly screwed
just because they had a rather small number. Still, the numbers are something we don't wanna ignore,
and if anything, we need to supportive of woman who are having problems with their body image,
whether or not they recieved breast implants. So, what do you guys think?
Has anybody you know ever recieved breast implants? Are breast implants positive for our society,
or are they only creating more body issues for woman who have and haven't recieved them?
Check out the article in the description, and let us know what you think.
If you like this video and you wanna see more videos with me in it, go ahead and click thumbs up.
And if you wanna see more videos from Psych2Go, go ahead and click the subscribe button.
Please, also make out to check out our Twitter, our Tumblr and our Facebook page.
The link are going to be down in the description. Thanks for joining me here at Psych2Go and I'll se you next time!